توم زكي في مهمة للقضاء
على مفهوم الهدر ، فعملية
رمي شيء ما في حد ذاته ليس سيئًا ، إنها في
الواقع مريحة بشكل لا يصدق ، تكمن
المشكلة في المكان الذي ينتهي فيه الأمر وهي
مشكلة كبيرة لم يحدث أبدًا أن 91٪ من النفايات البلاستيكية
التي تم إنشاؤها على الإطلاق  تم إعادة تدويرها ، لذلك
قرر زكي الذهاب إلى المصدر
لاستهداف الشركات التي تصنع نوع
الحاويات البلاستيكية ذات الاستخدام الواحد والتي
ينتهي بها الأمر باستمرار في سلة المهملات ،
وبدأ مع أكبر أربع
شركات للسلع الاستهلاكية في العالم مجتمعة
بلغ إجمالي مبيعاتها ما يقرب من مائتي
خمسة وثمانين مليار دولار في عام 2018
ذهبنا إلى جميع هذه الشركات الكبرى
قائلين إن هذه الفكرة الكبيرة الجديدة
تعال إلى المخاطرة بها ودعنا
نغير العالم بشكل مثالي في العملية التي
أطلق عليها الفكرة الكبيرة التي طرحها على
المستهلكين من خلال نفس المنتجات المنزلية التي تستخدمها
أحب بالفعل بالإضافة إلى وديعة
صغيرة وسنرسلها إليك في
عبوات متينة قابلة لإعادة الاستخدام عندما تنتهي من
إعادتها لتنظيفها وإعادة تعبئتها وإعادة
استخدامها من قبل شخص آخر كيف
كان هذا صعب البيع - تعلمون أن
العدسة المكبرة للمصنعين والشركات مهمة ضخمة
لأننا نذهب إلى شركة Procter &
Gamble ونقول إعادة اختراع
تغليف هذه المنتجات المشهورة عالميًا
لبناء خطوط إنتاج بالكامل
لملء هذه الحزمة المعاد اختراعها أوه وبواسطة
بالطريقة التي لا أملك فيها دليلًا على ما إذا كان أي شخص
سيشتريها على الإطلاق ، لكنهم قالوا نعم
لأنهم يعرفون أن هناك أزمة قمامة
وأنهم لا يريدون حقًا
المساهمة فيها ولم تكن شركة نستله بحاجة إلى
الكثير من الإقناع ، لقد استثمرنا الكثير
موارد الأشخاص وطاقة الوقت والدولار
لأننا عندما نفكر في
المستقبل ، نعلم أن المستهلكين
سيطلبون المزيد من المنتجات القابلة لإعادة التدوير ، والمزيد من المنتجات القابلة لإعادة الاستخدام
، وبالتالي فإن حلقة المشروع هي
وسيلة بالنسبة لنا لتوجيه إصبعنا إلى هذه
المنطقة ،
تعلم الكثير حقًا في النهاية
إلى جانب Procter و Gamble PepsiCo
، اتخذت Unilever Clorox وآخرون قفزة في نظام
العدسة البيئية إذا كانت مجرد
شركة واحدة تصنع عددًا قليلاً من المنتجات ،
فلن تنجح في
حاجة الجميع إلى القدوم  gether
وأصبحوا نوعًا ما نوعًا ما تعرفه عن
تأثير كرة الثلج حيث كلما
زاد حجمها ، انضم المزيد والمزيد من الشركات إلى
حلقة أسرع وأسرع تم إطلاقها في أوائل عام
2019 في عدد قليل من المدن مع حوالي 300
منتج منذ ذلك الحين ، يقول زكي إن أكثر من
10000 شخص لديهم  اشترك في
التوسع ليشمل المزيد من المدن أيضًا ،
وستتوفر المنتجات قريبًا في
كبار تجار التجزئة مثل Walgreens و
Kroger ، الأمر الرائع هو أنه يمكنك شرائه
من أحد بائعي التجزئة وإعادته إلى
الآخر حتى يخلق هذا
التأثير الرائع للشبكة.  إضافة علامة تجارية
كل يوم وحتى تعرف أن الأشياء التي
تراها من منتجات الحيوانات الأليفة إلى منتجات السيارات ،
فهي ليست مجرد نوع واحد من
الشامبو ولكن عشرات الأنواع المختلفة من
الشامبو وكل شيء
ينمو ويدفع بعضنا البعض
ما زلنا لا نعرف ما إذا  ستدرك الحلقة
ما تعتقد أنه يجب تغييره
فيما يتعلق بعقلية المستهلكين
حتى يتمكنوا من تبني هذا النموذج الجديد
الذي تقترحه
، وأعتقد أن مطالبة المستهلك
بالتغيير  أي شيء هو معركة شاقة ،
أعتقد أنه من الأسهل كثيرًا أن أسأل النموذج
عما يمكنه فعله لمطابقة الراحة التي
يريدها المستهلك ليست هي أول
فكرة لإعادة التعبئة موجودة على الإطلاق ولكن لم
ينطلق أي منها بالفعل وأعتقد
أن السبب هو  إنه أقل ملاءمة
للمستهلك ، ثم يتخلص منه بعيدًا
ويشتري واحدًا جديدًا ، وكلما نجعله يشعر
وكأنه أسلوب حياة يمكن التخلص منه ، أصبح من
الأسهل الحصول على اعتماد جماعي